protests continued to rage in New York
City this past weekend as mobs of
leftists expressed their shock and
outrage over the death of violent
criminal vagrant Jordan Neely protesters
flooded the subway system shouting no
justice no peace and at one point they
even jumped down onto the tracks right
as a train was arriving at the station
uh watch
[Applause]
[Music]
Christmas
this presents a bit of a new spin on the
famous trolley problem if you're
familiar with that though some would
argue that in this case there really is
no no problem there's no dilemma we also
came very close by the looks of it to
seeing a political demonstrator
literally touch the third rail
which I'm not saying I would never say
that I wanted to see that happen I would
never say that I would never say it
but apparently nobody was harmed except
for all the normal working people who
were simply trying to get on with their
day and instead found themselves in the
middle of a mob with a collective IQ
that barely cracks triple digits one
journalist covering the scene caught
this interaction between
um a man a black man trying to get off
the train in order to get to work and a
group of protesters who took this as
some sort of personal affront watch
dude
true
[Music]
yeah it's a little hard to hear what's
being said there but she's assuring him
well take a different train you're not
gonna be late for work you with your
stupid job
that's right sir you know I'm sorry but
these these protesters have decided to
use the subway system as a platform for
their performative uninformed emotional
outburst and so your job will just have
to wait
your need to provide for yourself must
uh take a back seat to their need to get
footage of themselves protesting so they
can post it to tick tock this is this is
a life in New York City now you might be
accosted by a psychotic Drifter while
commuting to your job or you might be
accosted by a mob protesting on behalf
of a psychotic Drifter while commuting
to your job of course if you are
actually killed by a psychotic Drifter
as plenty of people in New York City
especially in the subway are every year
there will be no protests on your behalf
that's just that's life in the big city
but as the dumb brainless mob carried on
being a dumb brainless mob more
information about Neely came to light
and it's now abundantly clear based on
reports dating back a decade that Neely
was a known Menace that's important he
was known people that took the subway
every day in New York knew about this
guy a known Menace who had apparently
been terrorizing commuters in the subway
system for years
which is why he was arrested all those
times and yet released back onto the
street every time
as the daily wire reports quote a man
who said that he was previously
assaulted by Jordan Elias speaking out
about his experience in the wake of the
untimely death of the 30 year old nearly
died last week after U.S marine veteran
named Daniel Penny and at least two
others restrained Neely following
alleged threats and erratic behavior on
a New York City subway train quote he
should have been in some rehab center
said Philemon Castillo Balthazar
speaking of Neely speaking to New York
daily news baltazar said that he was
assaulted by Nelly while he was waiting
for a train back in 2019 he says that he
was approached by Neely out of nowhere
and punched in the head
he said quote I felt a punch to my head
he didn't say anything he just hit me he
hit me above my right eye
the assault victim added that Penny
shouldn't be punished for his actions
now balthazar's experience sounds
similar to another Neely victim who is
also spoken out this is from the New
York Post this time it says an assault
victim of the dangerous homeless man
choked to death by a marine on a
Northbound F train this week ripped the
city for not forcing her attacker to get
the mental health treatment he clearly
needs and Mitchell tree said she was
randomly punched in the head in June
2021 by Jordan Neely inside SK Deli
Market on 2nd Avenue in the East Village
the attack caused swelling and
substantial pain but left no permanent
damage after police arrested nearly
Mitchell tree 65 assumed her aggressor
would face charges and psychiatric
lockup and uh she was sadly mistaken in
that case now if you've been following
the story you might hear about Ann
Mitchell tree
and think that well this this is the
case that resulted in the active warrant
that was still out for nearly at the
time of his death there was a there was
a warrant out for his arrest but you'd
be wrong because Mitchell tree is 65
years old
the victim in the other case is 67 years
old
now it's understandable that you would
get them confused as Neely was going
around assaulting multiple elderly women
this man was such a horrendous scumbag
that when someone refers to the
grandmother he brutally assaulted you
have to respond by asking which one
of course the the race Hustlers on the
left are pretending as always that the
violent predatory history of their
latest racial martyr is somehow
irrelevant Chief race Hustler Alexandra
Casa Cortez tweeted on Saturday quote
watching media give the Brock Turner
treatment for the killing of a homeless
man has been nauseating
a person having a record does not excuse
killing them neither does being poor
sick or homeless virtually every one of
us is closer to being in nearly shoes
than we think
well speak for yourself AOC I am I I can
say and I'm I'm no saint by any measure
but I can say that I am nowhere near the
point of walking up to a 65 year old
woman and bashing her over the head okay
I'm I'm nowhere near that
uh if you personally feel those sorts of
inclinations that's your own issue
as for the claim that his record doesn't
excuse killing him well you're obviously
missing the point and intentionally so
the point about his violent history is
first of all
that it should at least cause you to
refrain from turning this man into a
canonized martyr
even if his killing was unjust which it
wasn't
uh even if he is a victim a murder
victim and it's a terrible terrible
thing again I don't concede that it
still would be absurd to pretend that
you're deeply mourning the death of a
violent predator
who apparently contributed nothing but
violence and misery to his community
look 13 000 people die every hour across
the world every day
okay it's a lot of people
it is at a minimum
totally absurd to have a week of
national mourning over the death of a
violent Criminal Who assaulted old
ladies I mean you can claim that every
death is sad in its own way maybe that's
true but why have you chosen this one
like lots of people we don't have to say
across the world lots of people die
every day in this country
there have been plenty of other murder
victims just in New York City over the
past couple of weeks
and many of those victims had no history
of randomly threatening and assaulting
pedestrians so why not choose one of
them
why this guy
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep that's why you need to
check out Helix mattress Helix has
harnessed years of extensive mattress
expertise to fought to bring their
customers a truly elevated sleep
experience they just launched their new
Helix Elite the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for years now I absolutely
love it night after night I sleep like a
sweet sweet baby and I want the same for
you to sleep in your own mattress not in
mine just to be clear Helix has a sleep
quiz that matches your body's type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you want to
buy a mattress made for somebody else go
to helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type their flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away for a limited time Helix
is giving you 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
take advantage of this amazing offer at
helixsleep.com Walsh with Helix better
sleep starts now you know the weather is
warming up here in Nashville old do you
know what that means it's barbecue
season I don't want to brag but I make a
mean Burger the last thing I want to be
doing when I'm getting ready to host a
barbecue is driving around worrying
about where to refill my propane grill
tank and that's why I'm a huge fan of
cinch cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
tanks right to your door cinch delivers
on your schedule and does not require
any long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait at home for them
to show up you can track the order on
the Cinch app from anywhere could not be
easier whether you're grilling for the
sweet baby gang camping with your family
lighting up your fire pit on a cold
summer night whatever it is Essentials
propane delivery service ensures you
have the fuel you need to make the most
of every moment so go online to
cinch.com or download their app to order
new customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Walsh she'll go to cinch.com or
download the Cinch app and use promo
code walls to get your first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks that's
c-ynch.com promo code Walsh is a limit
time order and you must live within a
cinched service area to redeem it visit
cinch.com offer for details why are you
pretending to be sad about the death of
Jordan Neely when we all know that if
he'd been killed by some other black
homeless guy you would say absolutely
nothing at all you would step over his
body on the street and keep walking
without missing a Beat
so why nearly then well we've already
answered the question his death is
useful to you
there's also another more practical and
immediate reason why his brutal criminal
history is relevant
um again the regular commuters on the
subway knew him they knew about his
tendency to violence they knew he was a
danger they knew he was prone to Violent
outbursts
so there's a very good chance we don't
know if this is true but there's a very
good chance that the people multiple
people not just one who restrain nearly
on the train that day also knew this
about him or heard it from somebody else
said oh that's the guy that you know
and even if they didn't it doesn't
matter because the fact isn't nearly
made explicit violent threats even if
they were responding only to those
threats in the moment with no knowledge
of his background it would still be more
than Justified
now something else happened uh over the
weekend that I think ties into the story
though it may seem on the surface
unrelated NPR reports reports quote
California's reparations task force
voted Saturday to approve
recommendations on how the state may
compensate and apologize to Black
residents for generations of harm caused
by discriminatory policies the
nine-member committee which first
convened nearly two years ago gave final
approval at a meeting in Oakland to a
hefty list of proposals that now go to
state lawmakers to consider for
reparations legislation U.S
representative Barbara Lee who is
co-sponsoring a Bill in Congress to
study restitution proposals for
African-Americans at the meeting called
on States and federal government to pass
reparations legislation quote
reparations are not only morally
justifiable but they have the potential
to address long-standing racial
disparities and inequalities Lee said
the actual payments under this proposal
and it is just a proposal but if it goes
if it is uh enacted
it would be up to 1.2 million dollars
each for each eligible black resident
now
I've already explained why reparations
are a ludicrous unjust morally
incoherent idea we cannot allow people
to cash in on the injustices committed
against their ancestors centuries ago
because if we did that then everyone all
people on earth
should get a check
because we all have a suffering in our
bloodline we all have persecution in our
family tree
now which of us are in a better or worse
spot because of those historical
experiences it's impossible to say
you especially can't play this game with
slavery of all things given that slavery
is a global sin and there is no race
there is no group
which is innocent of it
Africa enthusiastically practiced
slavery until the late 20th century
we've talked about this before the
African country is the last country on
Earth
to legally prohibit slavery and that
didn't happen until 1981.
and as for the transatlantic slave trade
it you know it's it was African nations
and tribes that caught and captured and
sold the slaves into the transatlantic
slave trade so a black person in America
today
maybe the descendant of us of slaves
he may also be the descendant of slave
Traders he may be both
and many of us are likely both if you go
back far enough
how does this relate to Jordan Neely
well
because one argument he just heard it
there from the Democratic lawmaker
one argument for reparations is based on
the current condition of the black
community the the long-standing
inequalities as we're told
as the argument goes the black community
is in worse shape than most other racial
groups but nearly every metric
because of this historical Legacy of
slavery and these reparations would not
only redress the wrong but they would
also help boost the community and then
you know in a practical way repair the
damage
but practically speaking this is wrong
you cannot solve a person's problems by
just handing them a million dollars
look at the tragic history of of Mega
Millions lottery winners if you want to
learn more about that
besides
there is a better and more holistic way
to help this community
um
in fact I've got two there's just just
two ideas off the top my head
instead of reparations we could first of
all
stop lionizing and making role models
out of the absolute worst members of the
black community
okay the left makes Heroes out of
scumbags of every race
we know that but at the same time
there's no white George Floyd
um there's no white analog for Jordan
Neely
which isn't to say that there's there
are no white vagrant scumbag uh you know
uh psychotic criminals going around
assaulting people there are
but none of them are taken and turned
into Heroes
and on the right we typically chalk that
up to anti-white bias and it is
but at the same time as a white person I
don't I wouldn't want mentally ill
vagrants and drug addicted career
criminals presented as our Martyrs and
heroes
I wouldn't even want that
you know you tend to become what you
admire and these are the black people
that the left puts forward for
admiration
second one of the one of the best ways
to help any community
um is to put the dangerous people in
that community in prison
better than we talk about repairing
damage well instead of repairing damage
how about we prevent damage in the first
place and one way that you could do that
is by taking guys like Jordan Neely and
locking them away
you cannot pretend that you're
interested in helping the black
community while you insist on making
black neighborhoods more dangerous by
refusing to prosecute criminals
simply enforce the law enact Justice on
criminals and things will change for the
better almost instantly
that's my reparations plan tear down the
George Floyd murals
um disband the Jordan Neely protests
put criminals in prison
it's not going to solve every problem
but it'll solve a lot of them
and it's a good start
and it's certainly better than any
proposal at the left
is currently making I'll do it for this
portion shows move over members block
you can become a member today by using
Code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed